빌사남이 간다는 세계적인 도시 그리고
제가 좋아하는 마천루들이 모여 있는
뉴욕 맨하튼에 왔습니다
[음악]
네 어 저는 지금 페리를 탔는데 어
브루클린을 가기 위해서 페리를 좀
탔습니다 규가 너무 좋은 거 같아요
어 그래서 여기 페리를 타고 한
10분 정도면은 뭐 덤보 이동할 수
있기 때문에 여기 있는 직장인분들은
여기로 출퇴근 하기가 굉장히 좀
편리한 거 같아요네 사실 우리나라도
좀 이렇게 페리가 좀 발달했으면
좋겠는데 그 한강 공원이랑 거리가 좀
너무 멀잖아요 그래서 리까지 타는
데가 시간이워 오래 걸리기 때문에
만에 리 산을 좀 키운다고 하면은 어
선착장을 되게 좀 잘 만들어야 될 것
같습니다 여기 밤에 타면 진짜 예쁠
거
같아요 브로클린 브리지는 원래 한구
도시였습니다 어 이스트 강변에
위치하고 있어서 배가 드나들기 굉장히
좀 좋은 위치에 위치하고 있는데 근데
이제 맨해튼을 이동하려면 배를 타고
이동해야 되는 그런 불편함이
있었습니다 근데 지금 보이시는
브루크린 브릿지가 1880 13년도에
지어지면서 매네 인구가 이쪽으로 좀
많이 이주를 하기 시작했습니다 그래서
그때부터 경제 성장이 좀 일어나기
시작했고 근데 본격적으로 성장하게 된
거는
1970년도에 예술가들이 이쪽으로
이주를 하면서 여기 동네가 되게
힙해지고 상권이 굉장히 좀 좋아지기
시작했습니다 지금 보이시면 여기 앞에
있는 건물도 원래 공장 건물이었어요
근데 여기를 로프트 방식으로 좀
리노베이션을 해 가지고 여기
레스토랑이라는 오피스로 쓰고
있습니다데 한번 좀 직접 들어가서
로프트 방식을 리모델링을 어떻게
했는지 정확하게 좀 보여드리도록
하겠습니다
가시죠 아니 여기 너무 좋은데요 매네
브릿지가 이렇게 딱 보이는 곳에 나와
있는데 원래 여기가 되게 낡은
공장이었다 좀 진짜 되게 트렌디하고
힙한 공간을 좀 만들었습니다 그리고
지금 여기도 지형으로 되게 잘돼
있는데 여기서 딱 보는 그 매네
can 브릿지 모습이 너무 멋있는 거
같아요 그래서 여기서 그런 포토스팟
될 정도로 특이하고 뭔가 좀 재밌는
공간 같습니다 어 로프트 리모델링
방식에서 좀 말씀드리자면 어 예전에
예술가분들이 처음에 여기 왔을 때
아마 임대료를 좀 저렴한 것들을 좀
많이 찾았을 거예요 근데 일반
주어보자 아무래도 창고나 이런 공장들
위주로 좀 많이 들어간 걸로 좀 알고
있는데 그거를 리모델링 해가지고
바은게 이제 로프트 방식이라고 보시면
될 거 같습니다 로프트 방식은 제가
봤을 때 특징이 한 세 가지 정도
있는 거 같아요 일단 첫 번째로
층고가 되게 높습니다 어 예전에
공장이나 창고를 이용했기 때문에 일반
주거 시설보다는 층고가 굉장히 좀
높다라고 보시면 될 거 같고 그 두
번째로는 공간이 이렇게 막혀 있지
않아요 보통 주택 같은 경우에는 내력
벽이나 이런 벽이 굉장히 많은데
아무래도 이게 창고나 공장이었다
보니까 이런 벽이 없 그래서 내
마음대로 공간을 구획할 수 있는 그런
장점들이 좀 있고 그리 마지막으로
이런 창이 되게 커요 자연도 잘
들어오고 뭔가 햇빛도 진짜 너무 잘
들어와서 거주하기에는 좀 되게
트렌디하고 좀 좋은 공간이지 않았나
그렇게 생각을 합니다 근데 브루클린에
이렇게 좀 로프트 방식에 좀
리모델링이 많은게 여기 뉴욕시에서
되게 작렬을 많이 했어요 그래서 예를
들어서 세금 혜택이라 이런게 좀 있어
가지고 이런 기존 공장들을 부시지
않고 이렇게 모델링하는 방식을 좀
많이 썼다고 합니다 그리고 여기
인근에는 되게 신축 도들이 좀 많은데
이런 신축 도들을 지었을 때도 이런
세금 혜택들이 이런게 좀 많아서
여기에 고급 주택이라 아니면 이런
낡은 공장들을 이렇게 리모델링하는
그런 사례들이 좀 많아져서 젊은
사람들이 좀 되게 많이 찾고 인근의
좀 이런 분위기를 좀 많이 바꾸는 어
그런 부분이 좀 있었던 거 같습니다
여기 앞에 그 신축 콘도들 매각
사례들이 좀 있거든요 그래서 좀
설명을 드리자면 가격이 근데 생각보다
안 비어요 제가 여기에 신축 그
콘도도 한번 가서 봤는데 한
30평대가 한 20억 정도 됩니다
사실 뭐
조 있다 보니까 네보다 가격이 좀
싸긴 하지만 여기 신축 콘도가 위로
올라가서 뷰를 보면은 그 매네 뷰가
너무 좋거든요 저는 개인적으로 만약에
뭐 주거를 산다라고 하면은 브루
클린도 좀 많이 고민해 보지 않을까
이렇게 좀 생각을 하고
있습니다 뒤에 보이는이 건물에서 주거
시설 한 개 호실이 약 200만
달러의 매각이 됐습니다 하나로 치면은
약 한 26억 정도 되는데 평수로 을
때는 한 42평 정도 돼요 그래서
평당가로 한 약 한 6,200만 원
정도 됩니다 위치가 매네 can이랑
거리가 굉장히 좀 가까워서 브루클린
내에서도 입지적으로는 굉장히 좀 좋은
입지 같습니다 그리고 이쪽 상부층
같은 경우에는요 매네 뷰가 굉장히 좀
좋을 거 같아요 팬트하우스 같은
경우에는 브루클린에서 가장 뷰가
좋다라고 합니다 그래서 지금이
매각사례 같은 경우에는 매네 t 안에
있으면 사실 20억 원대 정도라고
하면은 진짜 뭐 원베드 아니면 투베드
정도 되는데 진짜 브로클린 와도
시설이 굉장히 좀 좋은 것으로 확인할
수 있습니다 그 금액 대비에서
가성비가 되게 좋은 거
[음악]
같습니다네 여러분 제가 매각 사례를
좀 설명드릴 건데 저기 뒤에 있는 저
건물입니다 2005년도에 로프트
방식으로 리모델링을 한 사례인데
하나로 약한 20억 정도의 매각이
됐어요 그리고 평수는 한 33평 그
평당가로 봤을 때 약한 6천만 원
정도의 매각이 된 그런 사례입니다
그리고 리노베이션을 했기 때문에 아마
세금 혜택이 있었을 것으로 좀 예상이
되는데 지금 이런 방식의 리모델링이
덤보 브루클린에 워낙 많습니다
세금적인 이슈 때문에 개발 업자들이
진입하기 굉장히 좀 좋은 거 같아요
그리고 지금 여기 다리만 건너면 매네
있데 네트는 정말 주거 환경이 좀
좋지 않은데 가격이 너무 비싸거든요
더 쾌적하고 좀 이렇게 깔끔한 그런
주거시설 원하시는 분들이 이쪽으로 좀
많이 투자를 하는 것으로 알려져
있습니다 그리고 지금 우측에 있는
신축 콘도가 있는데 신축 콘도의
가격이 여기에 거의 두 배입니다
그래서 왜 두 배가 됐고 왜 가격이
더 비싼지 제가 한번 좀 설명드리도록
하겠습니다네 어 지금 보이는이 뒤에
콘도가 최근에 매각된 사례예요 그래서
하나로 치면 87억 정도의 매각이
됐고 평수는 72평 정도 됩니다
그래서 평당가로 봤을 때는 1억 2천
정도인데이 왼쪽에 있는 리노베이션
사례보다 거의 두 배가 비싸요 그래서
그만큼 되게 비싼 콘도들 여러분들이
보시면 알겠지만 일단 신축 콘도그
세금 혜택 때문에 이렇게 개발업자들이
이렇게 좀 멋있게 어 지어서 분양을
한 것으로 좀 보여집니다 그래서
브루클린에 이렇게 오래된 건물을
리모델링하거나 아니면 이렇게 신축하는
건물들이 워낙 개발업자들이 좀
진입하기에 매력적으로 돼 있기 때문에
이렇게 고급 주거 시설들이 좀 많이
들어온 것으로 예상 개인적인
생각이지만 개발이 될 만한 지역들을
좀 이렇게 뭐 세금 혜택 이라든지
이런 인센티브를 좀 줘서 이런 좀
주거 시설들이 좀 많이 들어왔으면
좋겠고 리모델링을 할 수 있게 좀
이런 장려할 수 있는 방법들을 좀
많이 세웠으면
[음악]
좋겠습니다 저는 브루크린 브릿지 앞에
나와 있습니다가 속 감면서 놀는지
183에는지
탄로 지금 아직까지 그 관광명소로
이어질만큼 되게 상징적인 건축물이라고
생각이 듭니다 그래서 제가 오늘
촬영하면서 느낀 점이 총 다섯 가지가
있는 것 같아요 우선 첫 번째로
페리가 되게 괜찮다 생각보다 되게
괜찮다라고 좀 생각을 많이 하게 됐고
우리나라에도 되게 좀 훌륭한 페리
선착장이 패리가 많이 돌아다녔으면
좋겠습니다 두 번째로 건을 그대로
살려서 리노베이션하는 어 그런 방식을
되게 좀 놀랬고 주거 시설을 로프트
방식으로 좀 리모델링을 할 경우엔
저는 젊은 수요들이 굉장히 좀 많을
것으로 예상이 돼요 그래서 우리나라
건축법을 조금 개정한다고 하면은 이런
좀 공장을 로프트 리모델링을 해
가지고 좀 이런 젊은 사람들이 되게
색다른 주거 환경에 들어올 수 있게
그런 사례들도 좀 많이 들어왔으면
좋겠고 그리고 세금 혜택 어 세금
혜택 때문에 이렇게 개발 업자들이
들어오기 편하게 이렇게 좀 만들어
놓은 곳도 되게 좀 인상이 기뻤습니다
그니까 공간들도 너무 재밌난 공간들이
되게 많고 제 개인적으로 되게 살고
싶은 동네입니다 만약에 정말 만약에
뉴욕에 오게 된다면 유저지 아마
브루클린을 고민할 것 같은데 저는
아마 브루클린에서 살지 않을까네 그
정도로 브루클린 매력은 정말 엄청난
거 같습니다네 그래서 제가 한국에
돌아가서 여기서 느꼈던 거를 어떻게
접목할 수 있는지 좀 생각을 해보고
그리고 좀 당장 시간을 걸리긴
하겠지만 제가 언젠가는 뉴욕을 진출해
보도록
하겠습니다 렛츠
[음악]